and Karen Hacienda entered we'll talk
about an energy future that has been
talked about for many years in
electrification and its impact the
electrification I think of literally
everything what kind of impact would
that have I'm not sure you're going to
address that directly but is the
electric power sector really ready for
massive electrification and how will
this likely to affect national energy
grids and what will be the impact on
this kind of stress Nexus that we talked
about with water and energy use and
distribution so Karen I'll turn it over
to you thank you very much apologies for
not sitting down I'm much better on my
feet and I'm very grateful to be here so
thank you very much to the Yale climate
and energy institute I'm grateful to be
here for different reasons to Jang he
was very pleased to get away from the
the smoke and the smog I was very
grateful to see some real rain so thank
you very much I could do without the
cold though that's that's a struggle
today and so as Dave said I was I was
asked to focus particularly on the
electricity sector and today I want to
focus on three emerging or continuing
developments that affect very strongly
our capacity to generate electricity and
decisions around where and how we can
generate electricity so I want to
discuss those three issues and and then
conclude very briefly with what I think
the consequences might be for
electricity production moving forward
particularly the actors involved in the
business models that will underpin
electricity in the future so the first
issue which is very close to my heart
and which has been touched on already is
the electricity sectors demand for water
and it's my contention and others that
this nexus between electricity or energy
generally but electricity particularly
and water is going to place increasing
constraints on where and how electricity
can be generated to give you just a very
quick sort of pricey on that
link between energy and water just
consider for a moment that to produce
one liter of petroleum oil requires
anything from 7 to 15 liters of water to
produce natural gas you're looking at 20
to 50 liters of water per barrel of
equivalent oil and in terms of hydraulic
fracking which is a major concern in
Australia and and I know in the United
States as well you can be looking at
anything from eight to thirty million
litres of water produced per well / well
ok so the relationship between energy
and water is very very strong and we're
only really starting to come to grips
with that now the risks posed by water
to electricity in particular are four
fold the first is very obvious its water
availability ok do we have enough water
to be able to cool our power plants to
be able to extract those gas and oil
reserves the second is an increasing
ambient water temperature it's very
difficult to use water as a coolant if
it's already warm alright and we have
found this to be a real problem in
Australia the third is increasing
variability which exists anyway but is
going to be exacerbated by climate
change and the fourth is not mentioned
very much at all in any of the
literature and that is the the other
impacts of climate change that are going
to have an effect on critical
infrastructure so we're seeing
increasing cyclones increasing flooding
and even increasing bush fires in
Australia and elsewhere in the world
which is affecting your you know your
your your assets right we're seeing
plants destroyed or at least affected by
floods bushfire cyclones and the like
and so this is expensive which will
ultimately be passed on to the consumer
so it's a very real problem and it has
very real impacts almost everywhere in
the world we saw a very sort of perverse
outcome from the
delay in the monsoonal rains in India a
couple of years ago which meant that
there is an increased demand for
groundwater pumping in the absence of
the monsoonal rains which of course put
enormous pressure on the electricity
sector in India we've seen in the United
States in Australia in France in Germany
nuclear power plants and other power
plants have to shut down an interrupt
energy supply because of an absence of
available water resources ok so it's a
real problem and it's very much alive
once you throw land into the mix and you
bring in the consequences for
agricultural production and food prices
all bets are off and in 2009 we saw what
happens when you have a spike in staple
food products and so the oh I should
also point out that that there is no
particular technology that is immune
from this problem right the most obvious
is hydroelectricity alright but that's
that it doesn't stop there any kind of
thermal power generation is vulnerable
to scarce water resources anything that
uses water as a coolant is vulnerable to
ambient increase in ambient water
temperature okay fracking is another one
biofuels you know it's off the chart in
terms of water resource consumption so I
think understanding the Nexus is
starting to act on it is going to have
three consequences the first is we're
already seeing this is we're going to
see changes in standards around energy
efficiency around where you can cite
electricity generation plants and
there's going to be a whole suite of
water triggers within the regulatory
arrangements to ensure that sensible
decisions are made we're also going to
see things like code generation where
instead of using fresh water resources
we might see a desalination used and
we'll just cop the the energy cost of
that we may well see more efficient and
interconnected electricity markets to
promote greater
we have a national electricity market in
Australia so when we can't use our hydro
facility down south we can buy my energy
from up north right now that's great for
us but it's my contention that we might
actually see greater more flexible
competitive integrated energy markets
and electricity markets in places like
South East Asia okay where this issue
starts to get more and more live as they
develop further the most exciting aspect
of this to me and I share Dan's
enthusiasm about renewable energy
technology is that it just makes that
argument to use renewable energy
technologies that much more compelling
ok now the knock-on consequences of that
which I get very tickled pink about is
the potential for distributed energy
storage technologies to be a support
mechanism to enable that renewable
energy penetration and I don't want to
trample all over this afternoon's panel
but suffice it to say that in Australia
in the United States in parts of Europe
there have been some amazing initiatives
just in the last three years around
pilot projects for distributed energy
storage and what that is precipitating
in Australia at any rate is new business
models so just this week in Australia
the macquarie bank group applied to be
an energy retailer right it applied for
electricity retail license all right so
it's my contention that if we see more
renewables we see more distributed
energy storage we're going to see
different actors different people will
be producing energy and that's going to
require a whole shift in our regulatory
framework so that was the second issue I
forgot to start with that the third
issue is the persistent price
differentials that exist between regions
for electricity okay in Europe and in
Japan they pay to three at the moment
three times as much for their
electricity the world energy outlook
report from last year suggests that by
2035 they'll still be paying twice as
much
for electricity as the United States has
profound implications for energy
intensive production particularly
energy-intensive trade exposed
commodities and so where I think this
brings us to if we take the water energy
and more recently the land Nexus
combined with the penetration of
renewable energy technologies and what I
think that means for energy storage plus
the potential for greater incentive for
integrated grits more competitive more
flexible integrated electricity grids in
places where they're not currently
integrated I think we see a number of
consequences and and like Neil please
don't make investment decisions based on
this I think we're going to see
fundamental reform and in virtually
transformation of the electricity sector
in a number of ways we're going to see
reform of pricing particularly to
account for the externalities of water
impacts we're going to see new business
models new actors but new risks that
come with those new business models and
I'll go into that in detail in question
time if you like I think we're going to
see two weird things happen you know and
as a political scientist of course I'm
you know I'm focused on the role of the
state and who's doing what I think we're
going to see two things happen one is
we're going to have increasingly
decentralised distributed electricity
sectors so we've got more actors we've
got really innovative different business
models and we've got distributed energy
technologies renewable plus storage but
I think we're at the international level
we're going to see much more integration
and cooperation and collaboration to
allow for those very real climate risks
and water risks simply to bring about
greater energy security so I think it's
an exciting space and I'm having to
explore any or all of that in questions
you